mucho de lo que hemos hecho hasta el
momento con la transformada de la plaza
y la inversa en la transformada de la
plaza ha sido encontrar patrones pero
realmente no debería ser algo mecánico y
es por eso que vamos a hacer algunos
ejercicios para mostrarles por qué
funcionan y para asegurarnos de evitar
confusiones vamos a hacer una revisión
de todo lo que hemos aprendido hasta el
momento en el vídeo anterior vimos que
la transformada de la plaza de ft y
vamos a hacer una aclaración en notación
esto también lo podemos escribir como f
mayúscula de s y ya se los había
mencionado antes en el vídeo anterior
vimos que si teníamos que lidiar con la
función escalón unitario la transformada
de la plaza de la función escalón a
unitario que se convierte en 1 en un
valor c x una función desplazada
efe dt menos c
en el vídeo anterior vimos que esto es
igual a ala - c por s x la transformada
de la plaza
de esta función x f de s y es muy
importante no confundir esto con otra
transformada de la plaza propiedad o
reglas como le quieran llamar que
encontramos hace algunos vídeos si
siguen estos vídeos en orden habrá sido
hace unos 3 o 4 vídeos atrás y esta
regla nos dice
que la transformada de la plaza
^ aporte x ft
esto es igual y en este punto quiero
hacer una distinción muy clara aquí
arriba lo que hicimos fue tomar una
función que estaba desplazada y aquí
tenemos como resultado la transformada f
mayúscula de s pero aquí abajo estamos
multiplicando la por el elevado aporte
con lo que terminamos teniendo un
desplazamiento en la transformada fs - y
estas son dos reglas o propiedades como
las quieren llamar que son muy fáciles
de confundir así que vamos a hacer un
par de ejemplos para saber cuál usar en
cada caso y vamos a escribir todo lo
demás que hemos aprendido hasta el
momento lo primero que aprendimos fue
que la transformada de la plaza de uno
es igual a uno entre s
ese es bastante sencilla y en general
aprendimos que la transformada de
laplace dt elevado a la m siempre y
cuando m sea un entero positivo sería
igual a m factorial
entre ese elevado a la n-1
también encontramos nuestras funciones
trigonométricas cuyas transformadas
vamos a escribir en un color diferente
la transformada de la plaza del seno
de aporte
es igual
/ s cuadrada menos a cuadrada la
transformada de la plaza del coseno de
aporte es igual a s / s cuadrada más a
cuadrada y ustedes se sorprenderían
realmente al saber qué tan lejos podemos
llegar con solamente lo que se ha
escrito aquí aunque nuestra caja de
herramientas es más grande con solamente
lo que tenemos aquí podemos hacer todo
un conjunto de transformadas de la plaza
y transformadas inversas así que vamos a
tratar de hacer algunas digamos que ya
les di la transformada de la plaza y van
a esta es la parte difícil ustedes saben
cómo resolver una ecuación diferencial
si saben cómo tomar las transformadas de
la plaza con su transformación y su
transformación inversa lo difícil es
distinguir entre ellas aquí tengo la
transformada de la plaza
fs que es 3 factorial
/
hice menos dos a la cuarta ahora para
encontrar el patrón que le corresponde
la parte de nuestro cerebros que
reconoce patrones ustedes pueden decir
bueno yo tengo una transformada de la
plaza que tenga un factorial en él y que
también tenga un exponente así que esto
debe ser algo relacionado con esta regla
vamos a tratar de escribir la
transformada de la plaza que podría
corresponder a esto la transformada de
la plaza así que aquí tenemos un
exponente que es 4 así que nuestra m
podría ser un 3 t elevado al cubo esta
propiedad de aquí quedaría igual a 3
factorial entre s a la 4 bueno esto de
acá no es exactamente esto de aquí
arriba estos dos no son lo mismo y esto
lo estoy haciendo ahorita para
instruirlos pero yo me he topado con
estas cosas en exámenes recuerda que
cuando la primera vez que aprendí esto
pase por esta parte y en verdad uno lo
quiere tener errores por descuidos uno
quiere asegurarse de estar haciendo bien
las cosas
así que algo relacionado con esto veamos
cuál es la diferencia entre esta
expresión y la expresión a la cual
queremos encontrar la transformada
inversa de la plaza esta de aquí arriba
bueno pues vamos a desplazar nuestra efe
si llamamos a esto
a esta expresión efe de s
ds
concede esta expresión de aquí arriba
esta expresión de aquí arriba sería efe
de ese menos dos esta sería efe de ese
menos dos y con que estamos tratando
aquí como pueden ver aquí tenemos una
función desplazada fs así que en este
caso a sería igual a 2
esta es la transformada de la plaza de
elevado aporte x ft así que vamos a
escribir esto
esta es la transformada de la plaza de e
^ y que es bueno es nuestro
desplazamiento en este caso es 2
he elevado a la 2 porte
x nuestra función si ésta es fs cuál
sería nuestra gente sería t al cubo así
que la transformada de la clase esto
es igual a esto otro podemos escribir
que la transformada inversa de la plaza
3 factorial /
s - 2 a la cuarta es igual a e a la 2
por 'the x teal como bueno si esto les
pareció algo confuso pueden ir hacia
adelante vamos a hacerlo en la otra
dirección para que quede un poco más
claro si yo tuviera que hacer la
transformada de la clase de esto bueno
vemos que la transformada de laplace dt
al cubo es bastante fácil la
transformada de la plaza de esta pluma
no está funcionando bien y permítanme
hacer un poquito más de espacio aquí
para poder escribirlo si yo quisiera
encontrar la transformada de la plaza de
elevado a dos por 'the x t al cubo bueno
vemos que ésta es a la 2 x te implica un
desplazamiento así que yo sé que la
transformada de la plaza dt al cubo
éste es bastante fácil es igual a tres
factores entre s a la cuarta ya que es
tres más uno y la parte de la
transformada de la plaza a la 2 x te vas
esto pero desplazado esto es fs esto
cuando sea x
a la 2 x te va a darnos fs menos 2 y
cuales fs menos 2 va a ser igual a 3
factorial entre s menos 2 a la cuarta
creo que con esto comienzan a darse
cuenta de que la parte más difícil en
las transformadas de la plaza es lidiar
con todos estos desplazamientos y
reconocer los patrones para encontrar
cuál es la cual es la ce y tener mucho
cuidado al respecto pues no queremos
cometer errores por descuido y sin duda
a realizar varios ejercicios al respecto
nos va a ayudar muchísimo en esto para
que todo quede bien claro en nuestras
mentes y ahora vamos a hacer un problema
un poco más complicado no usan la
transformada de la plaza
de ese de una función
y ese transformada es igual a 2 x s
menos 1
x a la menos 2 s y todo eso está
dividido entre s cuadrada menos 2 s más
2 y esto es bastante difícil bueno tengo
una de aquí tengo un desplazamiento y
aquí tengo un polinomio en el
denominador como lo resuelvo cuando veo
estos polinomios lo primero que hago es
factorizar los de alguna forma y esto no
es difícil de factorizar de hecho en sus
exámenes que se encontrarán en las
clases de ecuaciones diferenciales nunca
les presentaran algo que sea factor
isable en números raros siempre tienden
a ser enteros así que tenemos que ver
cuál es los números que sean positivos
cuando se hace el producto de ellos y
cuál otro tendremos que agregar que sea
positivo o que podría ser negativo o
ambos negativos pero no hay dos números
que sean fáciles y ninguno de estos está
funcionando así que si no pueden
factorizar los directamente la segunda
opción es completar el cuadrado y quizá
esto coincida con alguna forma de coseno
como podríamos completar el cuadrado en
este denominador podemos
escribir esto como s al cuadrado menos 2
s
voy a poner un +2 aquí afuera y bueno
para que ustedes puedan entender esto
tengo varios vídeos sobre cómo completar
cuadrados para completar este cuadrado
necesitamos convertir esto en un
cuadrado perfecto y para hacerlo tenemos
que encontrar algo que cuando se agregue
a sí mismo dos veces nos dé este menos
dos y que cuando lo eleve al cuadrado se
convierte en uno más uno que cuando lo
hago al cuadrado queda más uno pero no
puedo agregar más uno arbitrariamente
aquí para poderlo agregar tengo que
equilibrar esto de manera que aquí
afuera lo resto
pongo un -1 y esto no ha cambiado sin
embargo ahora tengo esta expresión que
puedo transformarla en ese menos uno al
cuadrado y esta parte de aquí afuera
queda como 2 - 1
así que aquí nos quedaría un +1 por lo
que ahora puedo reescribir toda mi
expresión como
2 por s menos 1 por el ala menos 2 s voy
a hacer un poquito más despacio que para
que se note todo esto entre
s - 1 al cuadrado más 1
y ahora podemos notar algunas cosas
interesantes aquí
vamos ahora a tratar de hacer algunas
pruebas con algunas transformadas de la
plaza
por ejemplo la transformada de la plaza
del cosena de té
sabemos que esto es igual a s / s al
cuadrado más 1 que es un poquito
parecido a esto si esto de aquí fuera
una s y esto de aquí abajo fueron una
escuadra damas 1 si esto fuera fs que
sería esto vamos a ignorar esta por el
momento del vídeo anterior sabemos que
si tomamos la transformada de la plaza
la transformada de la clase
^ uno por t
a la 1 por t
por el coseno dt
todo esto tendría un desplazamiento un
desplazamiento de esa transformada de la
plaza en uno hacia la derecha por lo que
en donde encontremos una s la vamos a
cambiar por s menos 1 y así tenemos que
esto es igual a ese menos 1 entre s
menos 1 al cuadrado más solo y ya nos
estamos acercando ya hemos encontrado
esta parte de acá
en un vídeo anterior me parece que fue
hace dos vídeos o quizás en el vídeo
anterior no me acuerdo bien les mostré
que si tenemos la transformada de la
plaza de la función escalón unitario en
c
dt multiplicada por una f dt con un
desplazamiento de c
esto era igual
e
elevado a la
- ce por s
x efe de s
bueno aquí hay que poner mucha atención
porque puede resultar confuso y por eso
tenemos que tener mucho cuidado acá
vamos a ignorar esto que llame fs antes
pero ahora vamos a regresar nos un poco
y vamos a ignorar esto por el momento
voy a redefinir nuestra fdf y vamos a
definir nuestra fdp como esta parte de
aquí digamos que ft es igual a alarte
por coseno de t
y si tomamos la transformada de la plaza
de esto nos va a dar que fs
va a ser igual a ese menos 1 / s menos 1
al cuadrado más 1 aquí no hay nada
complejo simplemente define mi efe dt
como esto y mi fs como esto otro ahora
tenemos una situación aquí en la que
bueno en esta expresión vamos a ignorar
este 2 es un factor escalar que podemos
ignorar tranquilamente esta expresión de
aquí la podemos reescribir como bueno si
esta es nuestra fs esta expresión de
aquí será igual a 2 x nuestra fs x y a
la menos dos por s vamos a describir lo
en otro orden para que quede un poquito
más claro es 2 x el ala menos 2 s x f de
s
y esto luce igual que esto de aquí
arriba así que nuestro 2 es igual a
nuestra c esto nos dice que la
transforma de inversa de la plaza
y si éramos la transformada inversa de
la plaza de esto y de nuevo vamos a
ignorar por un momento este 2 bueno no
mejor vamos a hacer la transformada
inversa de la plaza de todo esto así que
la transforma de inversa de la plaza va
a ser igual a recordamos que este 2 es
un factor escalar lo podemos sacar
multiplicado por esto
la función es que la humanitario
y cuál es nuestra sed hacemos una
comparación de patrones y tenemos aquí
un menos aquí tenemos un menos dos pues
nuestra se va a ser igual a 2
nuestra función escalona unitario va a
ser igual a 0 hasta que llegue a 2 que
va a ser igual a 1 cuando te sea igual a
1 x nuestra función con un
desplazamiento de 2
- 2 así pues esta es nuestra
transformada inversa de la plaza y bueno
cuál fue nuestra función nuestra función
o fue esta parte de aquí así que la
transformada inversa de la plaza de esto
que había escrito es esto
efe dt que es igual a la t coseno de t y
vamos a escribir ahora todo completo
nuestro resultado completo
establecimos que no está transformada
inversa de la plaza destacó se norme que
escribientes
2 por s menos uno por el ala menos dos
por 'the perdón a la menos 2 s no
debemos tenerle aquí entre s al cuadrado
menos 2 s más 2
es igual a esto donde ft es esto lo
podemos describir como dos x
la función escalón unitario que comienza
en 2
dt
x efe dt menos 2 y está ft menos dos
esto colate reemplazada por t menos 2
quedando
a la t menos 2 por coseno dt menos 2
y bueno ustedes quizás estén pensando
que no debemos de estar haciendo esto
pasito a pasito para explicarlo pero
estoy haciendo esto poco a poco para que
yo misma no me confunda y creo que es
esencial que ustedes se tomen la
molestia de hacer esto paso a paso y
vamos a revisar cuáles fueron estos
pasos que hicimos para resolver este
problema
vimos que queríamos convertir este
denominador en una forma que fuera
vagamente útil para nosotros por lo que
completamos el cuadrado aquí y
reescribimos nuestra transformada de la
plaza nuestra fdc como esto y después
hicimos un reconocimiento de patrones
tomando la transformada de la plaza de
cocina de té obteniendo esta forma de s
/ s cuadrada + 1 pero esta es una s
menos 1 / s menos 1 al cuadrado más 1 lo
que significa que estamos multiplicando
nuestra función original en el tiempo x
elevado a la 1 por t aquí está el 1 y es
por eso que llegamos a esta expresión
así que la transformada de la plaza de
el alto por coseno dt quedó como s menos
1 entre s menos 1 al cuadrado más 1 y
esta es la menos 2 s en todo este tiempo
nos dimos cuenta que esta era la menos
12 s en nuestra transformada de la plaza
si tomáramos la transformada inversa
esto debería ser la función escalón
unitario multiplicado por la función con
desplazamiento y es por eso que fui
especialmente cuidadosa teníamos este 2
todo el tiempo que bueno lo pude haber
resuelto en un primer momento pero estas
constantes se pueden ignorar hasta el
final ya que una función x 2 es igual a
la transformada de la plaza de esa
función multiplicada por dos y viceversa
pero es por eso que fui especialmente
cuidadosa redefinir a efe dt como esto
efe bs como esto y dije bueno si efe de
ese sexto y lo multiplicó por al menos 2
s
entonces lo que esencialmente estoy
haciendo es coincidir con este patrón de
acá así que la respuesta a mi problema
fue utilizar la función escalón unitario
aquí incluye el 22 x la función escalón
unitario por mi función f dt desplazada
por c y establecimos que ésta era
nuestra efe nt así que si la desplazamos
con c que ésta se fue igualado pues nos
quedó esta respuesta como ven esta fue
la parte más difícil a resolver la
transformada inversa de la plaza espero
que hayan encontrado esto bastante
interesante